let me give you another name for this
same thing kind of an informal day but
you'll see why now these were what these
identities are these are often called
trig expansions you may hear me say that
phrase sometimes tree big stages right
the idea of taking this small a single
function but then breaking it apart to
something bigger right just like you
know we do algebraic expansions and I
was comparing it you know okay and I
could say expand right
I could take spared that and would mean
get rid of the brackets and make it into
something with more terms okay and it's
the same thing kind of with tree right
now let's just write in a short form
therefore that we learned yesterday
okay now I'm going to write it like so
sine of a plus B so a plus B let's see
if we can remember it let's see if we
grab it I'll give you a clue it starts
with the same right we tend to have that
shot the order of the angles so it's
going sine and cos B plus cos a sign
they excellent now I could write out
that's the first one I could write up a
second identity as it's only right but
because the only difference between this
one in the next one is a minus sign
right this is often written like so plus
or minus plus or minus okay do you see
how you just have to be careful right
which once you match up but the pluses
go with the pluses and the minuses go
with the minus B that's fine okay when
we did cause we notice is ever so
slightly different if we do cause up a
plus me the first difference is that
instead of sides and causes pairing up
like so you get the sides and causes
pair up with each other okay so here I'm
gonna have closed a cos B okay because
it's cause the sign of the middle will
not match we - and then there'll be sine
a sine B over here another way to
remember which ones which is that it's
alphabetical
just like on the unit circle okay now I
can write this one in the same way that
I wrote this one with my plus/minus
notation but if this one's plus/minus
the Plus here does not match with the
Plus here right so you will actually see
no joke this is a symbol instead of
writing plus latest they'll write minus
plus right because they mean this plus
goes to this minus and this minus goes
to this plus so that's it okay these are
the four that we established with
geometry
yesterday the very first one and then we
went from there algebraically and with
identities three others so then we
wanted to do ten okay ten so if you want
to do ten of a plus B okay ten is just
sine of cos all right so of course and I
know what both of those are so I'm just
going to go ahead and write them about
sign a plus B here cos of a plus B yeah
and I'm just going to put down the
expansion right I'm gonna put down these
expansions that I've got any sign a
caused the expansion okay this does look
like an old lady mess but we can make it
nicer I mean in one fell swoop
okay I want you to remember so when we
were looking at hard a trigonometric
equations right what does it look like
this for example when you've got
equations like this where the sines and
the cosines were all mixed together okay
we've learned a trick that could convert
this into something which was just one
trig function and then we could solve
what did we do okay good so we'll divide
through by some power of cause in this
case because I got squares here here it
would cost squared okay so when you do
that this and become tan squared this
will become ten and this will just
become minus 1 right so that worked you
divide through by cosines right I can do
exactly the same thing here because I
have the same situation I'll drop the
sides and cosines all mixed together the
question is what cosines should i / okay
now there's more than one choice but you
will find the quickest way to get stuff
nice and neat is closed air Cosby so I'm
gonna divide it on the top and I'm going
to divide it by on the bottom because I
I don't want to change the theme so I
have to divide by one right but I'm
gonna do it up by so now haven't think
about this and we'll just do it term by
term have a look at the first term on
the numerator if I divide this by close
a close be okay for starters because
bees bail cancel okay so those two kids
with each other and what you're left
with is side a enclose a right which is
better you're gonna get the same thing
happening here accepting to be the cause
David cancers right so I'm gonna get 10
B right now I'm go to the doughnut cos a
cos B divided by cos a cos B 1 minus and
then my signs and causes match up here
so I'll have 10 pay fee and that's it
that's as simple as it gets
now when we were going from the addition
the sum identity to the difference and
the sum identity to the difference we
took advantage of the fact that sine is
an odd function and cosine is an even
function
what kind of symmetry does Ted have Ted
is odd right so therefore and just put
I'll put it on the side here 10 of -
something because it's all it is - tan
on the same right not because I can just
take the minus sign out it's because
it's an odd function right so therefore
when I write Ted of a minus B do the
difference for this okay it's the same
scenario as this but everywhere I could
be I'm gonna have minus B so this tan a
is the same I could write this as plus
tan of negative B right some are based
on this instead I can write Y understand
baby right can you see that see what's
happening on the numerator the same
thing will happen on the denominator but
I've already got a negative there so
that negative plus the negative I'll get
from 10
baby will be no cancel each other out
I'll get fuss so become one pause okay
so if I want to do the same thing as I
did here right and put both of them
together into one and sometimes you'll
see textbooks do this I could combine
both of these and say it's head of a
plus or minus speed is gonna be equal to
and you notice the signs on the
numerators they match see that so I can
write this as 10a excuse me plus or
minus 10 B yeah but on the denominator
the signs do not match they don't match
when I have a plus here I'll have a
minus and if I have a - I'll have a plus
so I'm gonna be the same thing array
with cosine right all right as one minus
plus 10 a 10 B yeah can I just say a
quick nap before we leave off this do
not write this minus plus thing if it
just confuses you okay there's nothing
wrong with just writing these out as six
identities instead of three okay but
it's kind of less to remember if you can
wrap your head around that handle
different confused with each other
question they may ask you to prove one
from another okay so for instance you
know how we went from the first one and
then you can get all the rest of them
yeah they wouldn't ask you to replicate
that first proof from memory like that's
quite involved and there's lots of
different ways to do it but being able
to get the identities from each other is
quite important yeah that's right that's
right because think about what's
required to move from point A to point B
if that was the question okay and the
answer is you'd have to know about all
that even functions and what that means
you have to know about you know how sine
and cosine relate that they're
complements that kind of thing and you
have to be able to shuffle around these
identities which is all part of the
course all right now those are all of
the standard tree expansions but you can
see there are special versions of all of
these if instead of two arbitrary angles
random angles a and B suppose the two
angles were the same if they were both a
okay so if it was solid of a plus a
right yeah anybody say not say
interesting okay if the two angles are
the same then over here on the left hand
side I'll write sine 2a plus a right I'm
going to ignore the a minus a case for
now because this is double of an angle
this is called a double angle formula or
double angle identity okay now since
it's a plus a again everywhere I see big
I'll replace it with an eight right so
this first part will become sine a cause
a and this part would become cos a sign
a which is the same thing right so it's
just two of them to sign a cause a right
when I do that same kind of thing for
cause and replace my B's with a this has
become cos a cos a cos squared a and
then this guy will become side a side a
right so - what's that watch that this
is easily confused with the Pythagorean
identity but it's not the same thing
Klaas squared a - one last one well last
one we've tape if I do turn to a what
happens on the numerator it become ten a
plus 10a so me - 10 a right and then
what happens on the denominator everyone
- 10 a 10 a which is 10 squared okay now
it is very difficult to overstate how
important what is on the board is okay
it's kind of like oh she's memorizing
all this stuff is it all that important
yes it is because it goes to all these
other important places okay in fact
they're the places we're gonna look at
over the next couple weeks and for the
rest of the HSC cost let me outline a
couple for you
I already gave you a bit of a spoiler
that uh one of the first things they're
going to use this for is for calculus
okay so this goes to what we call a
process called differentiation which we
will learn about very very soon
okay differentiation is a huge idea if
you want to do it with any of the trig
functions you need this identity you'll
see it in time
that's where that goes let's see there's
uh the same formulas actually all of
these all of these they go to something
called auxilary angle right which we're
gonna learn in week ten auxilary it's a
technique for solving very weird Valley
trig equations right like we've looked
at standing equations treat equations
where there's things squared or cubed
etc and this this will open up a whole
new suite of problems there's one more
thing one more thing like this identity
here it also goes to something important
because it's um about the tan result
it's called the tea results or tea
formula okay same idea so all of these
identities they go places right so
that's why it's really important to
noted them very well
okay first question you will see I mean
do you remember how I prove the identity
for sine a plus B right I had to go to
geometry
right I do go to triangles okay but then
after that I didn't touch each triangle
again for any of the other five or or
these three even right so what we will
do is we will use this first result
disperser top for differentiation right
to establish it and then once you
establish that all the other everything
else comes for free right everything
else flows on from that result but you
need this
ten of negative to a all right well okay
so let's do it let's do a sign all
negative just for the safer okay this
this site is an odd function so this is
minus sign to a right right
which is minus 2 sine a cos a plus 2 a
is equal to cos of minus 2 eight because
causes an even function okay so the
short answer is it depends it depends on
what the context of the question is for
instance to pity on the context and what
I've asked to do with this I could just
as easily go here or I could go I might
I might put this out now when we learn
later on I said that this thing is going
to a part of calculus called
differentiation differentiation is a
process that you do and it has a reverse
as well called integration okay now when
we do integration these kinds of
questions come up and in fact what you
might have to do is convert these guys
even further to something else because
remember see how this is in terms of cos
squared and sine Squared's but cos
squared to science fits a sort of
interchangeable through the Pythagorean
identity you remember that right so for
example this side squared here I could
substitute it out for what 1 minus cos
squared right cos squared minus 1 minus
cos squared this is going to become 2
cos squared minus 1 if that's what I
wanted or alternatively instead of
getting rid of the same square I could
have gotten rid of the cos square and
this would become this okay now all of
these different versions in different
contexts are more simple than the others
depending on what context you're in but
I don't know
so you have to look at the individual
question often it will tell you for
instance use this to expand it to
something else right or you might see
for instance if the question you got
looked like this
right now tell me is this simpler or is
cause to a simpler and it's pretty
obvious which one is simpler right
because because then you can just get a
um you can just get an exact value out
of that right whereas this is some
garbage okay but just as many times
depending on the context instead of this
nice neat thing you have something which
is more complicated here when you use
the identity some factorization you know
cause by the side and cause plus side
comes out which is useful to you or who
knows see this is the thing treat
equations identities they come up
everywhere everywhere right like every
time you use your phone and you call
someone they use this three-dimensional
technique called Fourier analysis to
make sure that your voice comes through
clearly
even after traveled how many kilometers
to the air the bolus electromagnetic
interference and it's all in terms or
trig functions right so these problems
they come up everywhere and in a variety
of places and so I can't give you what
is